we're getting an inside look at the
growing underground vaping industry as
more states take steps to fight the
health risks linked to e-cigarettes
Washington is now the fifth state this
year to ban the sale of flavored vaping
devices and this comes as a total of 27
deaths across 22 states are being tied
to vaping in our eye on America series
Carter Evans shows us the black market
industry for on regulated vaping
products containing THC that's the
active ingredient of marijuana and how
they are bought and resold this event
that we're going to tonight just seems
to be a group of vendors that have
gathered together informally in one
place so they can sell their fake
cartridges this is the illicit market
for THC vape oil to find out how
dangerous and potentially deadly vape
products end up on the streets
we brought hidden cameras to a warehouse
75 miles east of LA where marijuana's
black market feels more like a house
party the THC oil inside these
cartridges is unregulated there's no way
to know exactly what's in them and how
it could hurt you everyone claimed to
have a pure
[Music]
it's places like this where some people
come to buy hundreds of vapes at a time
so they can resell them nationwide so
here's what we got
why would you buy these when you can go
and buy a certified product in the store
well it's price these are a lot cheaper
these were about twenty dollars apiece
you go buy them in a store they're about
$60 apiece there's been so much media
coverage about the legal market and no
one's been covering the Elissa market
mark owashi runs an app called doja that
provides customer reviews on cannabis
products a year and a half ago long
before reports of deaths and illnesses
across the country he noticed something
people we're getting sick like they were
getting headaches under this product
this is the product
many of the vape cartridges came from an
underground scene like the one we went
to the current black market comes with
you know a cartridge that has a brand
that has social media that has web sites
and it's really hard to distinguish
between what is a legal cannabis product
and what is an illicit product that's
becoming a big problem for art push gear
good morning Carter as he founded pure
vape a legal THC oil producer licensed
in California
by law his tamper-proof faves include
warning labels in lab results right on
the package are you worried that someone
might try to copy your packaging and
defective or dangerous product very much
so he's already seen counterfeit pure
Veit products on the black market and
warns customers if they're purchased
from the stores that is not an illegal
list we cannot guarantee if they're
getting an authentic favorite product
even if it says pure vape on the package
even if it says pure a upon a package
unfortunately I know it's crazy but
that's the truth we took our
black-market vapes to Bell Kosta labs in
Long Beach
miron Rene is CEO what's the worst thing
you've ever found
I'd say predominately in the underground
market what we're seeing is just a slew
of pesticides that was the case for the
illicit vapes we picked up they failed
for a total of five pesticides including
one called michael o butanol when you
heat Michael butanol you're then getting
hydrogen cyanide cyanide something you
definitely don't want anything no what's
the message here chopped legal you're in
a state that doesn't have legal chemists
don't buy it
black marketed THC vape cartridges are a
tough problem to combat especially in
states where marijuana is still illegal
and federally the Food and Drug
Administration doesn't regulate THC
products because it's still considered
an illegal drug tarika Carter what an
eye-opening report thank you really
interesting most of these cases around
the country of people with lung injuries
the CDC is saying they're tied to the
THC stuff and and many people presume
the black market stuff Street stuff so
don't do it if you haven't started and
if you're smoking cigarettes and you're
on an e-cigarette make sure you're
buying an aboveboard illegal company
just say no yeah